try and get outside ideally within the
first five minutes of waking or maybe
it's 15 minutes but certainly within the
first hour after waking this is grounded
in the core of our physiology there are
literally hundreds if not thousands of
quality peer- reviewed papers showing
that light viewing early in the day is
the most powerful stimulus for
wakefulness throughout the day and it
has a powerful positive impact on your
ability to fall and stay asleep at night
so this is really the foundational power
tool for ensuring a great night's sleep
and for feeling more awake during the
day second of all if you wake up before
the sun is out you can and probably
should flip on artificial lights in your
internal home environment or apartment
or wherever you happen to live if your
goal is to be awake if you wake up at
4:00 in the morning and you need to be
awake well then turn on artificial
lights once the sun is out however once
the sun has risen then you still want to
get outside and view sunlight hey it's S
car Michael and I make these videos
because I need them for me because I
want to wake up every day and watch a
video that puts me in a mindset set to
believe in myself more and go off and
accomplish amazing things and attack the
day and I hope that this video does that
for you as well so today let's learn how
to win the day and embrace the routine
of high Achievers
enjoy some of you will wake up before
the sun comes out and if you're asking
whether or not turning on artificial
lights can replace sunlight at those
hours unfortunately the answer is no
unless you have a very special light
we'll talk about what kind of light the
bright artificial lights in your home
environment are not I repeat are not
going to be sufficiently bright to turn
on the cortisol mechanism and the other
wakeup mechanisms that you need early in
the day the Diabolical twist however is
that those lights in your home or
apartment or even on your phone are
bright enough to disrupt your sleep if
you look at them too late at night or in
the middle of the night so there's this
a symmetry in our retinal our eye
biology and in our brains biology
whereby early in the day right around
waking you need a lot of light a lot of
photons a lot of light energy and
artificial lights generally just won't
accomplish what you need them to
accomplish but at night even a little
bit of artificial light can really mess
up your so-called circadian your 24-hour
clocks and all these mechanisms that
we're talking about so if you wake up
before the sun is out and it's still
dark please turn on as many bright
artificial lights as you possibly can or
need but then get outside once the sun
is out routine number two is start with
a run with David Goggins what does a
morning look like for you at the moment
if you got a routine of some kind yes I
run every single morning so that's what
time are you up when are you waking up
I'm up about 5 5:30 so every morning
starts with a run and that's because
that's the one thing I hate to do more
than anything in the world so that's
like my cup of coffee and I'm all about
armoring yourself so the second you
leave your house and the second you open
your phone the second you do any of that
you are now letting them poison in
cancer so I make sure a lot of things
you can't avoid so as I get up I start
to armor plate my mind and body like a
person's going to war you put your body
armor on that's what I'm doing on that
run I'm waking up and I'm giving myself
all this armor so when I come out in the
world now look at that phone I'm ready
I'm not waking up late I'm not rushing
around I'm not disorganized because I
know I'm going to get hit in the mouth
there's a there's a art to getting hit
in theing
mouth and that is why these things are
important you have to wake up and you
have to give your self- belief you have
to give yourself confidence so that it
starts with that run so after the run I
come home I eat something small how long
to run typically at the moment nowhere
Under 12 miles so 12 mil is the minimum
and what are you getting that done in
how long it depends right now I'm
running a heart rate so I'm running like
815s 830s because I'm retraining right
now because is that zone two for you
zone two because of the leg surgery I
had so I'm going back starting from
scratch so anywhere from about an hour
30 to two hours I run every day routine
number three is eliminate your
smartphone with Mel Robbins your mindset
and having a powerful mindset and being
deliberate about what going to think
about and what you're not going to think
about it begins the moment you wake up
and believe it or not how you wake up
not when but how you wake up and the
first few things that you do in the
morning will dictate your mood for the
rest of the day which based on science
is going to impact your productivity and
it's going to impact how you feel about
your life and it will also
impact your mindset for the rest of the
day you can think about your morning
routine and whether or not you even have
one in the exact same way that we think
about the brain you're either defaulting
to something that you've always done
that may not no longer serve you or
you're getting deliberate and choosing
to do something that's more positive and
Powerful because you deserve it and that
starts with your morning routine so if
you're the kind of person where the
alarm goes off and you hit the snooze
and then the Al goes off again and you
hit the snooze and you know eventually
you roll out of bed and you step into
your day and you maybe drink a big dark
cup of coffee and you skip breakfast and
you skip exercise and you're tired if
that's how you start your
day your mindset is going to be impacted
by that if your alarm goes off and you
immediately reach for your phone and you
start scrolling through Instagram while
you're in bed and looking at Facebook
and you are putting all kinds of stuff
in your brain that triggers fomo that
triggers insecurity that triggers
anxiety that is going to impact your
mindset for the rest of the day and so
starting tonight I want you to take
control and be more deliberate about
your habits in the morning the
assignment tonight is very
simple and you're going to hate
it you're totally able to do this and
most of you are not going to you're
going to let your limiting beliefs and
your default mode of thinking stop you
from making this simple change and the
thing that I want you to do tonight this
is your assignment this Smartphone right
here I don't want it anywhere near your
bedroom your assignment is when you go
to bed tonight you are to plug your
smartphone in outside of your bedroom if
you live in a studio apartment
put it on the other side of the room I
don't want this phone anywhere near
where you sleep and there's a simple
reason
why you're addicted to it and if it's
next to you while you're sleeping as
soon as you wake up without even
thinking the default mode of your brain
will mindlessly reach for this and you
will lie in bed and you will look at
your phone and when you do that you are
putting in garbage into your brain
before you even get out of bed if you
wake up anxious if you wake up
overwhelmed if you wake up feeling like
you're losing some imaginary race if you
wake up and you feel dread if you wake
up and feel negative or exhausted I'm
telling you this is the reason why and
if you want to have a positive mindset
this year and you deserve to then you
also have to get very deliberate about
your habits and about your morning
routine in particular because how you
wake up matters how you wake up
determines your mood also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there routine number four is reverse
engineer your day with Jim quick I
believe if you want to win the day you
have to win that first hour of the day
you have to win that morning and my goal
is really not to distract ract myself so
when I wake up first thing in the
morning I will go through and I will say
okay what's the most important things I
get done today because it's not about
being busy right we're addicted to
busyness sometimes we say oh people ask
how's your day and what are you up to I
just like I'm so busy and and we use
busyness as maybe like a badge of honor
and what we're really saying is that
we're busy so we must be important but
the goal is not to be busy because then
we start designing our day around being
busy and we wonder why we're stressed we
wonder why we are overloaded so what I
do is I say okay let's say and do this
with me please wherever you are in your
day right now if you were to fast
forward at the end of the day and
somebody was to ask you a maybe a family
member or friend how was your day and
you said wow it was amazing today was an
incredible day I crushed it reverse
engineer it what had to happen in order
for you to say those words what happened
during those days what things did you
accomplish who were you being doing
sharing and so on for me I think of
three professional things I want to
accomplish I feel that if our to-do list
is 20 things or 50 things or even 100
different things then we're just being
busy the most important thing is to keep
the most important things the most
important things and you could do
anything but I believe you can't do
everything certainly you can't do
everything at once so what would three
wins be for your day routine number five
is plan ahead with Brenan brashard you
must always begin your morning with
going over your schedule and your goals
never never never just show up to work
without that plan you need to have that
plan you need to that morning be very
clear about what the day is what's
important and why and if you don't do
that yes you can still hit high
performance yes you can still be great
but you will not be as consistent as you
could be there's something magical and
you guys all know this I spend 20
minutes every morning just looking at
the day literally it might just be I
might only have five things I have to do
that day but I'm going to I'm SP I'll
sit 20 minutes thinking about each of
those five things that amount of thought
and intention that goes into it allows
me to show up and do a lot of things you
see me do people always say geez Bron
you just you just show up and talk I'm
like yeah but I I probably gave it a
good 20 minutes this morning of thought
some people say oh my gosh you know you
get so much done it's like yeah because
you know what when I was thinking that
morning about the full day I also
usually asked a lot took out a lot uh I
know I have to get things done so what I
do I pushed away a bunch of things that
I already had on schedule today from
weeks literally weeks or months ago
they're gone so I can refocus today to
make sure that I finish some of that so
your morning has to be planned routine
number six is Kickstart your morning
with tea with J shett the first thing I
consume at the beginning of the day is a
cup of tea I find that tea has this
unique ability to start your your day
with Stillness there are so many
benefits to having a cup of tea in the
morning stress alleviation immune system
support and detoxifying it all starts
with the process of heating up the water
now I'm old school I don't use a kettle
I was always taught to heat up my water
like this on a stove and for me this is
where the mindful process begins from
filling it up to watching the water to
watching it heat up once the tea is
poured I take a moment to inhale the
scent this is such a Mindful and
meditative practice if you're someone
that struggles with being in the moment
of meditating this is a great way to
start start by looking at the color of
the tea then by inhaling and taking in
the beautiful scent and then taking a
sip I promise you it's an experiment in
presence and you'll be so engaged and so
involved that you'll recognize what it
feels like to live in the now this is
one of my favorite ways to start the day
because my mind is at ease it's calm
it's peaceful and at the same time my
body feels like it's getting this warm
hug and that I'm feeling the energy all
across my body and routine number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is start with gratitude with
Galas as soon as you are up every single
day number one begin your day with
gratitude don't just charge your phones
watches tablets all laptops the first
thing in the morning charge yourself up
as well with positivity that will last
you all day and the most powerful of all
positive emotions that'll make you feel
empowered is gratitude because it forces
you to shift your attention to your
blessings than to your problems which
are anyways going to be an integral part
of all of our Lives second resolve to
have a positive vision nobody including
ourselves is perfect everybody has a
good and a not so good side to them and
the tendency of the mind is to look at
the not so good side every morning
resolve that you'll try and look at the
positive side of people and neglect or
deal with the dark side because the more
we focus on the negative our mind
becomes occupied with others faults
ruining our work our day our peace our
joy and even our
relationships what your current morning
routine looks like so I go through five
s's uh sing Sun sore sweat scare so sing
I put on music right away and any song
that will get you like if it came on
you'd have to bounce and you'd have to
sing right yeah um so right now there's
a there's a Chinese rap that I did it's
a Chinese song that I did a rap in
English on top of yeah and so I play
that every morning um Chinese rap is
like dance or is it like straight up
like hardcore rap uh I'm rapping yeah to
a Chinese song so it's this woman who's
rapping and I sped her up and then I'm
rapping over the parts where she's not
singing that was a fun little project
that I worked on um so I like it it
makes me move so I I'm rapping to my own
song every morning while it comes on but
whatever song gets you up and ready to
go cuz we wake up and you know you're
tired and starting your day and so music
is the fastest way to change your state
like as soon as it comes on in 5 seconds
you can already be feeling better right
oh yeah and there's no one Magical song
that's whatever it is for you and the
audience um then Sun so I like to get
outside so we got two dogs are in here
with us today I like to get outside
outside just to get some fresh air on my
face we're in Toronto it's December
there's not a lot of sun happening right
now but just just getting out of your
environment even if you work from home
the the walk from just your bedroom to
the office you can carry with that still
the tired energy of the bedroom right so
get outside get some fresh air even if
it's um just go out on the balcony and
just take in some sun for a little bit
mother nature mother nature makes a
difference um then soar so this is the
most important part what is the thing
that you need to do every day that makes
you feel bold powerful Unstoppable
confident alive whatever that thing is
do it first thing in the morning
instead of waiting like maybe it's
listening to the PVE your Paradise
podcast or watching the video series now
it's happening if that's a thing then
then you watch it every morning you
listen to it every morning um most of us
don't have enough intention behind the
day yeah and so I know it's part of what
you do in the morning too but for me
it's uh I go live on Instagram so
service if I feel like the work that I'm
doing matters is important I'm serving
somebody it it makes me more amped up
for the day totally so I'll go live on
Instagram every morning and people join
in from around the world asking
questions and I help them and quick half
hour um and that's what I need to do so
other people maybe it's meditation maybe
it's prayer maybe it's something like
anything whatever the thing is that
makes you feel bold powerful confident
if you started your day with the thing
that made you feel bold and Powerful
your your year is going to look totally
different like where you are in one year
will be totally different than where you
are right now amen um and then the last
two are just sweat and Scar so I'll do a
workout and then hop into a cold shower
because like what do you like to do for
working out um usually do uh 100
push-ups 100 squats what am I doing now
100 push-ups 100 squats and 100 jumping
jacks yeah and then you do like the Wim
Hoff the whole like cold hot that's it
uh not hot just cold just cold just cold
yeah there's no hot in the Wim Hoff no
no I mean like the cold like the whole
the the Heat and coolness like you get
really worked out like sweaty and then
you do the cold then jump into the cold
yeah arguably the single most important
Improvement I can make in my life to
improve my life
is to upgrade my morning ritual or to
create a morning ritual and and the idea
is that how you we start our day sets
the tone and the context and the
direction for the rest of the day and
therefore our life and if you win the
morning you win the day if you start the
day by putting yourself in a Peak
Physical mental emotional and spiritual
State you are a better version of who
you were when you went to bed the night
before and if that's how every day
begins you enter the day energized and
clear and and ready to go on fire and so
so I decided okay if I'm going to do the
morning ritual I'm going to create the
ultimate morning ritual like I want this
to be I'm so I was so tired at six
months into this downward spiral I was
depressed I was I was every I was just
falling apart and so I created these six
practices which we'll dive into today
and uh they I didn't know how to do any
of them like one was meditation I had
never meditated in my life one was
affirmations I thought affirmations were
really goofy like what do you just you
pump yourself up you know and uh but I
but the next morning I woke up an hour
earlier than normal which the
interesting thing was I thought it was
going to be hard because I wasn't a
morning person but it was actually like
I was a kid on Christmas Eve the night
before I was so excited to wake up and
try this new ritual the alarm went off
the next morning I woke up jumped out of
bed I did the six practices and I sucked
at them I was terrible like I wasn't
good I didn't have to meditate I was bad
at all of these things however even
poorly executing this self-care ritual
by 6:00 a.m. I felt so clear I felt so
energized motivated and I felt hopeful
and maybe that's the most important
piece because I believe that one of the
major causes of depression is when you
lose hope and after six months of you
know being optimistic at first
eventually life just beat me down and I
got scared and I didn't know what to do
and that very first day that I did the
miracle morning it wasn't called The
Miracle morning but I did the self-care
practice I I had hope I went wait a
minute if I start every day like this
it's only a matter of time before I'm
able to to do the things I need to do to
create what I want in my life the second
layer is what are those self-care
actions so what are those self-care
actions that you've I mean developed and
refined and practiced and every morning
at 4:30 you get up and you do this every
day no matter what like so give us a
picture of those what are those
self-care actions so this This Acronym
uh the Savers these are the six
practices that make up the miracle
morning and the first s is for silence
I'll run through these real quick and
then I'll dive into just a couple the
first s is for silence uh that can be
meditation it can be prayer it can be
breathing exercises or for me it's all
of the above every morning for typically
about 10 to 12 minutes the A is for
affirmations these and affirmations I
think have been taught really
ineffectively for I don't know as long
as I've been around um by teaching us to
either lie to yourself if you want to be
happy just say I am happy until you fake
you know fake it until you make it kind
of thing but I found that the truth will
always Prevail and so if you say I am
and it's followed by something that you
do not believe in your heart you don't
resonate with and you're trying to
convince yourself or trick yourself I
think that can be better than nothing
but it's not the optimum way and we'll
dive into the optimum way here in a few
minutes the V is for visualization the E
is for exercise the r is for reading and
the final s in
is for scribing which as my good friend
JP SE says is a pretentious word for
writing um but for the acronym
journaling wouldn't fit at the end of
saber every morning after alms round in
the in the
monastery we would do our morning chant
sometimes before we went out some of
them when we came back and they were
chants of gratitude and prayers may I
use the food that's offered the the
robes that I've been given the care that
I received from others may I use this in
a way that benefits myself and the
community around me and all the beings
in this world may I take these and
receive it with deep
gratitude
gratitude the acknowledgment of the
countless blessings Great and Small that
we receive every single day with every
breath and every
meal gratitude has a trust a confidence
in life itself it feels the same force
that pushes grass through the cracks in
the sidewalk invigorates and keeps you
alive every
day gratitude gladdens the heart it's
not sentimental not jealous not
judgmental it doesn't Envy or
compare gratitude receives in Wonder the
Myriad offerings of the rain and the
Earth
and the care that supports every single
life you guys that are just getting
started you're not going to start right
here you're going to start down there
okay probably in another city another
town I grew up in Lake Charles Louisiana
no money raised by a single mother I was
in debt at 25 years old the first thing
that I had to do in my life was not
learn a new skill first thing I had to
do to get my life moving in the right
direction was self-development
it is vital it was vital for me that I
improved myself and I could start
depending upon me I had to show up every
day with some rituals some disciplines
and start getting myself to trust me not
trust others but trust myself to do the
right thing every day one of the things
that I started doing was beating the Sun
up every morning I'm going to beat that
sun up every morning so that I have the
discipline and the control o over my
life so I knew hey before that thing
pops I'm going to pop I'm going to get
out of bed depend on myself get up at
the same time every day and for me that
time regardless of where I was was beat
that sun up no matter where I am I'm
going to beat that thing up so it gives
me a sense of control over my own life
second thing I had to start cleaning up
my life and my friends and my
environment when I was younger between
15 and 25 I was doing crazy stuff in my
life wasting my weekends I have the
saying weekends are the week I was
drinking fooling around with a bunch of
bad things bad people making poor
choices at 25 years old I cleaned it all
up quit going to those places quit using
those things quit hanging out with
people that did not have ethics and
discipline in their life that weren't
committed to the same things that I was
I wanted to build something in my life I
wanted to become someone and to do that
to become someone in the eyes of the
world
the first thing I had to do was become
someone I could depend on so put some
things together three or four things you
can do every day to start the day
Kickstart your day get going in your day
to give you a sense of respect for
yourself accomplishment for yourself
look just beating that sun up every
morning gives me the sense of
accomplishment that I did what I said
said I was going to do that I woke up
when I said I would wake up and I start
building respect for myself start
believing in myself so that I can go out
into the world and maybe maybe maybe
today maybe today when I go into this
meeting that I'm dressed for maybe
they'll believe in me as much as I
believe in me and that'll show up in a
contract a deal maybe even some
money beat the Sun up the next best
predictor of Lifetime success is
conscientiousness well so and of the of
the two aspects of conscientiousness say
orderliness and and industriousness the
better predictor is industrious so the
question is well what can you do about
your industriousness and the answer to
that is well that's kind of rough too
because there's a strong genetic
component but you can work on micro
habits with regards to your
conscientiousness and I think the best
micro habits this is partly to do with
these future authoring program processes
I think the best thing you can do with
regards to your conscientiousness is to
set up some aims for yourself goals that
you actually value and the future
authoring program helps people do that
and basically it does a a situational
analysis of it helps you do a
situational analysis of your life more
than a psychological analysis I would
say and so the questions are something
like well all right you're going to have
to put some effort into your life and
you need to be motivated to do that and
so what are the potential sources of
motivation well you could think about
them in the big five manner you know if
you're extroverted you want friends if
you're agreeable you want an intimate
relationship if you're disagreeable you
want to win competitions if you're open
you want want to Eng engage in Creative
activity if you're high in eroticism you
want security okay so those are all
sources of potential motivation that you
could draw on that you could tailor to
your own you know your own personality
but then there are dimensions that you
want to consider your life across and so
we ask people about well you know if you
could have your life the way you wanted
it in 3 to 5 years if you were taking
care of yourself properly you know what
would you want from your friendships
what would you want from your intimate
relationship how would you like to
structure your family what do you want
for your career how are you going to use
your time outside of your job and how
are you going to regulate your mental
physical mental and physical health and
maybe also your drug and alcohol use
because that's that's a good place to
augur down you know because alcoholism
for example wipes out you know 5 to 10%
of people so you want to keep that under
control and then and then so maybe you
know you you you develop a vision of
what your life what you would like your
life to be and that
Associates the so the goal once the goal
is establish lished and then you break
down the goal into micro processes that
you can implement the microprocesses
become rewarding in proportion in
relation to their uh causal association
with the goal and that tangles in your
your incentive reward system you know we
talked about the dopaminergic incentive
reward system and that's the thing that
keeps you moving forward and the way it
works is that it works better if it
produces positive emotion when it can
see you moving towards a valued goal
okay well what's the implication of that
better have a valued goal because
otherwise you can't get any positive
motivation working out and so the more
valuable the goal in principle the more
the microprocesses associated with that
goal start to take on a positive charge
and so what that means is well you get
up in the morning and you're excited
about the day you're ready to go and so
as far as I can tell what you do is you
specify your long-term ideal maybe you
also specify a place you want to stay
the hell away from so that you're
terrified to fail as well as excited
about succeeding because that's also
useful you specify your goal you do that
you do that in some some sense as a
unique individual you want you want to
specify goals that make you say oh if
that could happen as a consequence of my
efforts it would clearly be worthwhile
because the question always is why do
something because doing nothing is easy
you just sit there and you don't do
anything that's real easy the question
is why would you ever do anything and
the answer to that has to be because
you've determined by some means that
it's worth
and then the next question might be well
where should you look for worthwhile
things and one would be well you could
consult your own temperament and the
other would be well you kind of look at
how look at what it is that people acrew
that's valuable across the lifespan look
look what so you do a structural
analysis of the subcomponents of human
existence and already did that you need
a family you need friends like you don't
need to have all these things but you
better have most of them family friends
career educational goals plans for you
know time outside of work attention to
your mental and physical health Etc you
know those are that's what life is about
and if you don't have any of those
things well then all you've got left is
misery and suffering so that's that's a
bad that's a bad deal for you so so once
you but once you set up that that goal
structure let's say and that's really in
many in many ways that's what you should
be doing at University is that's exactly
what you should be doing is trying to
figure out
who it is that you're trying to
be right and you you aim at that and
then you use everything you learn as a
means of building that person that you
want to be and and I really mean want to
be I don't mean should be even those
things those things are going to overlap
and it's important to distinguish
between those because that's partly and
this is back down to the micro routine
analysis so if I saying well you're
going to try to make yourself more
industrious okay number one specify your
damn goals because how are you going to
hit something if you don't know what it
is that isn't going to happen and often
people won't specify their goals too
because they don't like to specify
conditions for failure so if you keep
yourself all vague and foggy which is
real easy because that's just a matter
of not doing as well then you don't know
when you fail and people might say well
I really don't want to know when I fail
because that's painful so I'll I'll keep
myself blind about when I fail that's
fine except you'll fail all the time
then you just won't know it until you
failed so badly that you're done and
that can easily happen by the time
you're 40 so so I would recommend that
you don't let that happen so that's
willful blindness right you could have
known but you chose not to okay so once
you get your goal structure set up you
think okay if I could have this life
looks like that might be worth living
despite the fact that it's going to be
you know anxiety provoking and
threatening and there's going to be some
suffering and loss involved and all of
that obviously the goal is to to have a
vision for your life such that all
things considered that justifies your
effort I know you all have big goals Big
Dreams big aspirations just like I do
you've got Ambitions to become an
amazing person to build your career to
create to contribute to give to be an
awesome human being but all of that is
impossible without great habits setup if
you don't have routine and structure set
up in a way that will keep you on track
then you you'll fall off and and and
having new goals without new habits is
kind of like you know having a new car
without wheels you know the habits are
the wheels they are the things that make
you able to achieve the goals so you got
to have good habits but the challenge
for most people isn't that knowledge I
mean you know you need to have good
habits it's you can't keep the Habit
going right have you ever started it the
new year you're going to get healthier
and you start that habit of working out
more on a more regular basis and then it
goes away or you say you know I'm going
to be more kind and more patient and
more awesome to my partner my lover and
you start being nice for two or three
days and then on the fourth day you're a
jerk you know and you're like what what
happened I said I was going to be nicer
it's that you didn't set up the most
important thing you needed to maintain a
habit so what's the biggest secret I've
learned in almost 20 years in this field
it's so simple but most people don't
have it it's called trigger moments you
have to set up trigger moments to
activate your habits what do I mean by
that well let's say you want to become a
a better person you know you want to
become more kind more patient more
loving with people now you can just set
that intention or write that down in
your vision your journal or set up on a
vision board that you look at once in a
while but in daytoday life it's not
enough you need things to trigger you to
remind you to be that particular kind of
person right it's almost like if you
could have a little angel speaking in
your ear all day long to tell you what
to do and how to be you'd obviously
become better well that makes sense well
let's use that idea let's use that idea
by setting up alarms on our phones that
trigger us to do the very things we need
to do this is going to be so basic
you're going to laugh and then I'll also
tell you how I've literally taught this
to Fortune 50 CEOs and they said it was
the one thing that changed their life
the most dramatically so let's start
with this let's have a goal in mind
let's say you want to become more
present and calm throughout the day
again you could write that down on a
journal I'm going to be more present
present and calm you could meditate in
the morning say today I'm going be more
present and calm and you you could you
can start out with good intentions but
those fall apart without a trigger
moment set up throughout the day to
remind you that so what if you did this
what if you just set up on your phone
three alarms during the day with a label
that said close your
eyes take 10 deep breaths in remind
yourself to be calm so let's say you're
going through your day it's crazy right
it's 10:00 a.m. and all a sudden Bing
your phone goes off you look down and it
says close your eyes take 10 deep
breaths and then again it happens at
2:00 and again it happens at 6:00 p.m.
and again it happens at 8:00 p.m. what's
going to happen you always look at your
phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've talked to do
this hundreds of thousands and they tell
me all the time that that changed
everything and you'll think once you set
it up that the next day
you you'll you'll forget about it no
that alarm will go off you forgot you
set the dang alarm there it goes off in
your face you're like all right I'm
trying to be calmer and more present
close my eyes take 10 deep breaths
reground myself here we go you can't do
it once a day you have to have moments
throughout the day that trigger you to
enact the new Behavior I know this makes
sense to you but it's a challenge for a
lot of people because they never set
those things up so what if you did it
with an alarm arm so for example for me
on the opposite Spectrum I don't want to
just be calmer and more present I Want
More Energy throughout the day so here's
what I do one of my big trigger moments
is every time my butt hits a chair I
don't care if I'm on a plane or I was
like where we're shooting here I I wrote
a lot of my books here I wrote the
motivation Manifesto here I wrote The
Charge here and if I'm going to write my
butt hits the chair I grab my phone I
open the timer and I set 50 minutes now
at 50 minutes the timer goes it starts
buzzing and I look at that and I go oh
that's my trigger to get energy so I
stand up I go get some water I take a
glass of water drink it down I do some
stretches and I do some exercise just
really briefly or I'll go for a walk
whatever it is but I'll do something
that usually takes just 2 to 5 minutes
then I'll sit back down I'll set that
50-minute alarm and I'll work and what
that does is every 50 minutes it
triggers me to change how I'm physically
moving it changes my attention so that
throughout the day I'm continually
refreshed so I never have that 2 3 4:00
time where I'm like ah you know why
because I've triggered my day so that my
energy is maintained throughout the day
makes sense right this could be as
simple as let's say you want to be
healthier in your life okay let's set up
some trigger moments for you in this way
let's say every time you drop off the
kids on the way back to the house you
stop at the grocery store and get some
fresh produce
that's just a trigger it's like okay did
one thing drop kids off now tied to that
triggered from that action drop kids off
is go to health food store or let's say
you want to get healthier in the morning
one of the easiest ways to help people
maintain a better exercise program is
this set a trigger you wake up in the
morning your first action is to drink
water put your exercise shoes on uh
might get dressed if you were naked just
saying so you get dressed PR put your
shoes on you go downstairs or you go to
the gym and that's the trigger you woke
up you do these actions nothing
interrupts those actions that's the
action and you have to have those set up
one of my other favorite trigger moments
to set up is doorf frame triggers what
do you mean by that when you walk into a
new room to have a psychological trigger
go off in your mind that you've
associated with that door frame so let
me give you an example if I walk into my
house at night if I've been working all
day and I'm going to walk in I'm going
to see my lady I have it so when I ever
walk through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said the three words
said the three words and I did this so
many times that now when I walk through
a door my mind automatically triggers
those three words and I remember to be
those three words so what words would
you love to have describe you you as a
person that you would be happy if that
was how people described you what would
those words be have those and now set
them up in your life I teach Executives
to do this as well I have them have a
doorframe trigger when they walk into
their office in the morning soon as they
walk through that door frame they have
boom three words go through their mind
about how they want to be perceived as a
leader I have them set up another door
every time they walk into a meeting into
the conference room when they walk
through the doors of the conference room
they have another three words that
trigger off for them and it just reminds
them how to be so these aren't big crazy
things a lot of people they think they
have to completely change their life
what would change your life completely
is setting up more trigger moments and
associations that when you see something
you do this that when this action is
taken then that happens that when you uh
have the opportunity to set up alarms on
your phone you set them up so that
you're interrupted in your everyday life
to remind yourself to stick to the
habits to stick to the intention you do
that enough on a continual basis you'll
find yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes I
talk to so many smart fantastic
ambitious idealistic hardworking kids
and they're right out of college they're
in their l jobs and I'll ask them how's
it going and they'll say I think I'm
going to quit and I'm like why they say
to me I'm not making an impact I'm like
you know you've been here eight months
right they treat the sense of
fulfillment or even love like it's a
scavenger hunt like it's something you
look for my Millennial friends they've
gone through so many jobs they're either
getting fired I mean it was
Mutual
or they're quitting because they're not
making an impact or they're not finding
the thing they're looking for they're
not feeling fulfilled as if it's a
scavenger hunt
love a job you find Joy from is not
something you discover it's not like I
Found Love here it is I found a job I
love that's not how it works both of
those things require hard work you are
in love because you work very hard every
single day of your life to stay in love
you find a job that brings you ultimate
Joy because you work hard every single
day to serve those around you and you
maintain that Joy it's not a discovery
but the problem is this sense of
impatience it's as if an entire
generation is standing at the foot of a
mountain they know exactly what they
want they can see the summit what they
can't see is the mountain this large
immovable object that doesn't mean you
have to do your time that's not what I'm
talking about take a hel opter climb I
don't care but there's still a mountain
life career fulfillment relationships
are
journeys the problem is this entire
generation has an institutionalized
sense of impatience and do they have the
patience to go on the journey to
maintain love to feel fulfilled or do
they just quit and on to the next dump
and on to the next ghost and onto the
next and by the way ghosting means the
lack of skill to have a confrontation
you date somebody for 6 Months 8 months
and then just stop
replying just delete them from
everything now for the person who's
doing the ghosting oh that's certainly
easier than a confrontation but the
person on the receiving end of the
ghosting it's like there's a death
they're suddenly shunned there's Panic
they call out they're worried they call
out their word they think it's you they
think it's them do you have any idea the
destruction that we reap on people by
ghosting them and then because there's
the lack of social skills to call out
and ask for help they internalize and it
makes them feel awful to the point at
the worst they will kill themselves
slightly one level down they'll get
depressed but the lowest level that we
can hope for is they will go through
life and I'm not talking about ghosting
I'm talking an entire generation that if
we don't fix this we'll go through life
where everything's just fine my
friendships are fine my work is fine you
know same old same old nothing's ever
amazing and the scavenger hunt
continues and then you go to the fourth
observation the most egregious of all of
them
environment we're taking a generation
that has lower self-esteem we're taking
a generation that has a lack of cop
coping mechanisms to deal with stress
we're C dealing with a generation that
wants all those things fixed immediately
and we're placing them in work
environments that values money more than
people do you you know that most of the
business philosophies most of the
business theories that we Embrace and
see as standard today are not standard
they're theories left over from the 80s
and 90s the concept of shareholder
Supremacy was a theory proposed in the
late
1970s it was popularized in the 80s and
90s the concept of using mass layoffs to
balance the books did not exist in the
United States prior to the
1980s it did not exist
it became popular in the ' 80s and 9s
the ' 80s and 9s were boom
years anyone could make money relative
peace a Kinder gentler Cold War and so
all of the business theories that were
put forth were very very selfish and all
about enriching ourselves and they
worked for those times but these times
are different these are not peaceful
times these are not boom years this is
there's GL mobilization in the internet
which has now made everything vastly
more complicated and those theories do
not work anymore worse they're having
side
effects it's really bad because what we
do is we destroy corporate cultures the
idea of using mass layoffs can you
imagine sending someone home and saying
I'm sorry I can no longer provide for
our family because the company missed
its arbitrary projections this year
that's what we're doing like a a coach
prioritizing the needs of the fans over
the needs of the players hoping to build
a great team it doesn't work we
dismantled things like the glass steagle
act glass steagle was passed after the
Great Depression to prevent another
Great Depression from happening it was
dismantled in the 80s and the 90s in the
name of
prophet okay do you know how many stock
market crashes we had between the Great
Depression and the dismantling of glass
eagle
the answer is
zero and since they dismantled glass
deagle we had 87 the dot crash 2008
we've had three stock market crashes
because we've removed the safety
mechanisms that prevent stock market
crashes from happening all in the name
of individual advancement and profit and
these are the corporate cultures we've
built corporate cultures that value
numbers over people and they are not
standard business practices they are new
and they are broken and they are
dangerous and we're asking a young
wonderful ambitious amazing generation
that needs us to work in these
environments whether we like it or not
we have to take responsibility for the
bad hand that you've been dealt it is up
to the companies to create an
environment in which you can build your
self-confidence it is up to the
companies to create an
environment in which you can learn
coping mechanisms and learn how to build
strong close relationships with people
with whom you work that you will
eventually love and sacrifice to see
that they
gain it is in these environments that we
will learn the patience and the hard
work that it takes to find fulfillment
in our lives to find a sense of purpose
a sense of
Joy yes it's all fine and good that my
generation and older Generations say to
you things like well you're the future
leader we're the leaders
now we're the ones in control of the
corporate environments
now and we're making your lives
worse I don't want you to jump from job
to job to job to job you will never find
what you're looking for it's not a
scavenger hunt I don't want you to go
from relationship to relationship to
relationship what I want you to do is
stand up and demand that the places in
which you work lead you
properly nobody wants to wake up in the
morning and be managed we want to wake
up up in the morning and be led and we
have a total leadership crisis in
America politics is just the mirror
reflection we get the politicians we
deserve We're The Divided ones we're the
selfish ones we're the broken ones we're
the ones who would soon to sacrifice
somebody else so that we may gain it's
us and until we're willing to do the
hard work of repairing the world around
us our country our politics our
businesses will not fix in that year
when I was really broken I was really
broken I was working at La Unified
School
District I was miserable I was miserable
because I wasn't living in my dream I
was just doing a j o and then one day I
said what what do I need to do I I need
to I need to buy my
freedom that's what I need to do I need
to buy my freedom oh I don't know about
buying my freedom I don't know about
buying I don't know about having money
saved up my family didn't have money
saved up my mother used to tell me oh
this money is burned in my pocket so I
know two things about money it's hot and
we can't keep it long we'd always have
one week where we had all the food in
the refrigerator and then one week where
we were the refrigerator was empty right
come on come on some of you guys know
about that to this day I spend so much
money on groceries you guys oh my God
it's like I'm feeding like a family of
10 cuz I'm so afraid of anybody ever
being at my house and being
hungry and so I I wrote a check to
myself
gelani was three
$110 I took it to the
bank Well
Fargo I started a new
account the next check I wrote
$125 and just like the first check I put
in the memo line funding my dream I
wasn't even clear what the dream was but
I knew there was something in my belly
who who in this room know you got
something in your belly there something
I'm not even clear about it I don't know
how clear you are but I wasn't clear
about it but I knew there was a calling
on my life greater than working for La
Unified School District and no
disrespect to La UniFi School drink it
just wasn't my
destiny I wrote another check in two
weeks
$146 funding my
dream now I started mailing the checks
in because I didn't want to see my
balance cuz I don't want to go
shopping cuz I you going to repeat what
you learn right until you decide to not
repeat what you've learned so I mailed
the check in and I wrote another check
and I wrote another check and every
check I wrote I made sure it was 5% more
than the first check the ne the previous
check I sold my Tima I had a car note
sold my Tima bought a clunker cuz it
didn't have a car note now I can write a
bigger check fun in my dream I moved out
of my three-bedroom three B three bath
house and moved in became a roommate
with my friend who smoked I put towels
at the base of the door so the smoke
wouldn't come through the door I was
willing to be inconvenienced are you yes
I'm just saying I'm just I'm just
showing you the story I just the charge
I just gave you I stopped getting my
hair done that was when I started going
natural I stopped going out I I stopped
going out dancing I sto going out to
dinners my family didn't know what was
going on they thought oh my God you know
it's La she's on drugs but she's not
losing weight so maybe not I don't know
what's going
on I kept writing bigger checks to
myself $900
$900 I mailed to W Fargo funding my
dream
$1,100 mailed to W far Fargo funding my
dream I still wasn't clear what what the
dream
was I just knew I had one and it was
being born through me and I needed to
give it a
chance that's all I knew you don't have
to see 2,000 ft in front of you just see
200 and run to the
200 yes yes yes yes you don't have to
see it all three and a half years later
I'd written a check to myself every two
weeks for three and a half years
I didn't go out for three and A2 years I
didn't go dancing I get didn't get my
hair done I didn't get my nails done for
three and 1 half years are you willing
to be in convenience for your
conviction I walk in to Wells Fargo
three and a half years later and I said
hi God bless you hi my name is Lisa
Nichols she go oh my God you're the fun
in my dream lady I was like yeah I guess
I am and all of a sudden all the tellers
came running around the manager came
they're like oh my God okay oh my God we
have been wondering we all got the same
question y'all know what the question is
right what's your
dream I was like
um I'm not sure but I know that it
includes inspiring
people having people believe in
themselves
again teaching them how to get back up
when they've been knocked
down having them to be willing to give
themselves a thousand Second Chances and
every time they get to $9.99 press
reset I'm not sure what it's going to
look like but it's just going to help
people I said I came to check my balance
I've been writing a few checks to you
guys I say yes you've been writing a lot
I said I just want to check my balance
you don't know your balance I said no I
got this really big stack of summary
bank statements at home home cuz my mama
said money Burns her pockets and I don't
want it to burn my pocket I want it to
pay for my
freedom I said I just came to see what
my balance was if I had enough to fund
my dream as it gets clear she wrote it
down everyone's excited she wrote it
down turned it around to me I looked at
it I said oh no my name is Lisa shant
Nichols and my social security number I
said that is not my money and I am not
taking that money because you're
probably gonna want it back so just fix
that error right
now and they looked at me they said you
really don't think that's yours I said
no my family's never had $5,000 in the
bank or $10,000 in the
bank that's
$62,500
in the
bank they said Miss Nichols and everyone
teared up the manager teared up the
tellers teared up
they said Miss Nichols whatever your
dream
is I think you can fund it now I looked
at my son jalani who now was five or six
and I said
jalani our lives are going to be a
little different now baby galani said
yeah Mommy can
we can we now go to
McDonald's see for three years I've been
telling galani I'll make you a Big Mac
Mama makes Big Macs better than
McDonald's and so it began with $110
check so I don't know what yours is I
don't know what your radical looks like
for some of you your radical was coming
here right yes yes and this is the
beginning yes yes this is the beginning
of your radical this is the this is the
be the next best step this is the first
step and so I just sto by to let you
know you're on the right
path and and as you ramp up as you ramp
up you're going to have questions you're
going to be afraid I do more things
afraid now than I do
Fearless cuz the bigger you play the
bigger your
breakdowns every single one of my errors
in the last five years have cost me six
figures like every single one every
single one of my errors has required me
to call an attorney
like they're just big cuz I'm playing
big I'm playing big so be willing to go
to the
edge and this is where you are here be
willing to go to the
edge and not just lean
over and feel the
breeze and watch the people
jump and watch them soar and look
through the window
at all the people who are living great
lives don't just go to the edge and feel
it be willing to
lean feel your heartbeat feel it that
lets you know you're alive that lets you
know you're okay fear fuels you fear
lets you know go get more information
fear lets you know step a little later
and study fear lets you know get up a
little earli fear let you know ask for
help fear is informing you it's not
stopping you it's just another emotion
like love and compassion and gratitude
we just made it paralyze us see fear
doesn't stop me fear informs me and when
you get intimately connected with the
fear I feel it and I'm moving forward
anyway I feel it and I'm going to love
anyway I feel it and I'm going to invest
in me anyway I feel it and I'm going to
show up and play anyway when you get
connected with fear it becomes your best
friend and when you stand on the edge
oh you feel the
breeze you feel the
fear and you leap
anyway because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for the seven steps on how to
build massive confidence check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there your new definition of
confidence
embodied by the research confidence is
the willingness to try confidence is an
action that's what it is and this
phenomenon has been heavily